before engaging in a physical workout
most of us will perform
some kind of warm-up we know this is
important to improve performance and
prevent injury
and yet we rarely ever consider the same
approach for the brain
we sit down at the computer stare at the
blank page and wonder why words aren't
just flowing
or we get to answer emails and wonder
why we can't stop checking facebook
never mind that we've literally just sat
down after a stressful commute
playing with the kids or perhaps
scrolling the news warm-ups for the
brain can be just
as effective at encouraging maximum
performance and they may
be precisely the missing ingredient you
need to enjoy greater productivity
and discipline there's ample evidence to
suggest that warming up the brain
can be effective at improving subsequent
performance in one study it was found
that a five-minute brain training game
used before maths or reading exercises
could improve outcomes this follows from
many other studies looking at priming
for instance maths exercises can aid
language tasks when used immediately
prior
exposure to specific words can improve
the ability to generate to recognize or
classify related terms
and other more unusual examples exist
too for instance reading an essay that
concerns the word i
rather than the word we can actually
improve reaction times
this is often referred to as priming
however priming can be used more broadly
to refer to activities such as listening
to music to impose a positive mood
indeed these can be effective measures
too one of my favorite videos discussing
focus and flow comes from the channel
better ideas
joey suggests that all the flow hacks
and tricks in the world
usually won't trump a simple fact
getting into a flow state takes time
and sustained effort why might this be
simple
the brain needs warming up but what if
instead of banging your head against the
wall for 20 minutes
this is how long joey suggests the
concentration hump might last
you could instead perform a simple
warm-up
complex training is an approach to
strength training that seeks to prime
the muscle
for greater force production via post
activation potentiation
this means that the neural pathways
involved in particular movements
will be primed to activate again more
easily this effect is why 100 kilograms
feels really light
after you've just been pressing 140
kilograms and it's why a coach might get
an athlete to perform a conditioning
activity
prior to training and expect to see
greater overall expression of strength
as you likely know already the brain is
brought to life by electrical activity
that travels between a huge network of
brain cells sometimes called
a connectome each synapse is a
connection between neurons
and can be thought of as a node in the
network when a neuron receives enough
electrical stimulation from its inputs
the presynaptic neurons it will continue
the chain by passing on that charge
this firing impulse is known as an
action potential
in order for an action potential to be
triggered in a given brain cell which is
how neurons communicate
it must first reach the threshold
potential this is somewhere between
minus 50 and minus 55 millivolts
whereas the typical resting potential is
around -70 millivolts
in skeletal muscle an increase in myosin
light chain phosphorylation
in type 2 muscle fibers results in
muscle cells becoming more excitable
and thus more readily able to contract
this excitability remains elevated with
a half-life of approximately 28
milliseconds
but what's really interesting is that we
see continued improvement in performance
for minutes after the event
this is sometimes described as post
activation performance enhancement
and it's the result of several other
factors blood supply to the muscle
alterations in muscle temperature muscle
cellular water content etc
and this is why a conditioning activity
can be effective several minutes prior
to the main exercise
similar effects may be at play in the
brain
following activation of specific brain
regions we see an increased blood flow
to those regions
thereby increasing available energy
moreover though we'll also see
alterations in the excitability of
neurons
modulated via neurotransmitters and this
is where things get
really interesting this is short-term
plasticity
or dynamical synapses two key processes
in short-term plasticity are enhancement
and depression
also known as fatigue these processes
increase or decrease the likelihood of
activation
respectively and can occur within
milliseconds as most of you will know
neurons do not only communicate via
electricity rather they also rely on
chemicals called neurotransmitters
you will recognize many of these such as
the feel good serotonin and the
goal-directing dopamine these chemicals
exert their effects primarily by
increasing or decreasing the
excitability of neurons
inhibitory neurotransmitters like gaba
and serotonin make neurons less likely
to fire
whereas excitatory neurotransmitters
like norepinephrine and dopamine and
acetylcholine
have the opposite effect pop science
tends to imply that our brain is full of
one chemical or another
at a given time if you're happy it's
because your brain is flooded with
serotonin
rather though these chemicals often act
in a far more localized fashion
at the scale of brain regions and even
specific connections this is one reason
taking a pill to increase dopamine is
not the smart fix we might assume it to
be
short-term synaptic facilitation a form
of synaptic enhancement
results from an increased likelihood of
presynaptic neurons
the inputs releasing neurotransmitters
due to any previous activity
and more specifically this is due to
increased presynaptic calcium
concentration
because more neurotransmitters are being
released synapses will strengthen for a
short time
resulting in increased excitatory
post-synaptic potential
hence a math's warm-up will prime you to
subsequently solve difficult maths
problems
conversely synaptic depression or
fatigue occurs when the readily
available neurotransmitter vesicles
become depleted vesicles are like sacs
which hold the neurotransmitters by the
way
this makes those synapses less likely to
activate
and these processes do not occur
exclusively but rather concurrently
and it's not that these adaptation
processes help to prime us to process
important new information for example
synaptic depression
may help us to focus more greatly on
novel stimuli
and it's easy to see how synaptic
facilitation could result in greater
focus
after a short period of effort or
heightened ability to recall specific
information
after previously retrieving it
synaptic enhancement can be divided into
subtypes facilitation augmentation
and potentiation these classifications
represent the duration of the effect
with facilitation lasting only a few
milliseconds whereas augmentation lasts
for seconds
potentiation post titanic potentiation
can last for minutes
and if you consider how signals spread
and propagate throughout a brain region
the lingering effect could be
cumulatively significantly longer
if you think of your connectome as a
complex network of roads then these
adaptation processes act like diversions
rerouting traffic through those existing
structures and potentially resulting in
entirely different outcomes
over time this may also lead to
permanent structural changes as the
increased likelihood of specific
patterns of activation
result inevitably in their becoming
reinforced via long-term potentiation
computer models of neuroplasticity
reveal short-term plasticity to have
profound effects over time
synaptic facilitation has even been used
as the proposed neural mechanism of
working memory
this may be what allows us to maintain
and manipulate information in the mind's
eye
although i should mention that this is
just one possible explanation
i also wonder whether this could go some
way to explaining the zeigarnik effect
too this is the effect that allows a
waiter to recall multiple customers
orders
only to fail to even recognize them
after their shift is over
information that is in active use is
more easily accessed
neurogenesis and gliogenesis the birth
of new brain cells
occur over the course of days which has
led many to presume that permanent
structural change
requires a similar time period but there
is ample evidence to suggest that
morphological changes
such as the formation of entirely new
synapses
could occur much more quickly in one
study structural changes that amounted
to variations in the density of brain
tissue
were observed in the brains of
participants using dti
following 90 to 120 minutes of a spatial
learning task
think about this for a minute as you
learn and play your brain is literally
growing and reshaping
like a time lapse of a tree to me this
seems highly intuitive
after all i've made no attempt to recall
what i had for breakfast
and yet i can do so with ease i'll
likely still remember this in a few days
facilitation doesn't explain this as it
happened hours ago
thus i suspect that structural
plasticity can occur
in an even shorter time scale and that
means priming your brain could actually
change the rows themselves
ready for action as well as the flow of
traffic the initial likelihood of
vesicles releasing neurotransmitters
varies from neuron to neuron
and this essentially allows certain
neurons to act like filters
some neurons we want to fire easily some
we want to be more difficult to activate
so the brain is super complex in other
words and this is to say that attempting
to boost your cognitive performance by
taking stimulants
is like trying to tune a radio with a
hammer this is not the key to better
focus and creativity
this could also present issues for those
hoping to use transcranial direct
current stimulation
we don't want to make every connection
in the brain more prone to firing
not even within a single brain region
but priming and warming up the brain
well that might be much more effective
because we can use exercises that
exactly mimic what we want to be doing
so with all that said how could you go
about warming up the brain and priming
it for action
we could start with some broader
systemic approaches full body exercise
will help to stimulate blood flow around
the body
and that will include the brain
listening to music that improves your
mood could also be helpful
if you're in a funk and can't focus the
right music could alter your hormonal
cocktail
as many hormones also act like
neurotransmitters this could also get
you in the right state of mind
but the secret weapon may well be to use
a cognitive conditioning activity
so if you need to write an essay you
could spend a few minutes writing
something else
to start priming the right networks for
action rather than just finding yourself
procrastinating and putting it off
because you can't engage with the task
likewise if you need to focus on the
dull work task then doing the simplest
parts of your job first could help to
warm you up and get you in the zone
if you're a programmer why not write
yourself a little program that does
something fun
in the space of 10 minutes short-term
plasticity also suggests that once
you've retrieved a piece of information
it'll be easier to retrieve it
subsequently this means that doing a
last minute cram before an exam
actually could be effective to help
improve recall subsequently
perhaps in the queue for the exam hall
all this is something that the folks at
neotrainer have been tapping into
neurotrainer is a suite of virtual
reality brain training tools
used by athletes and others that need to
be highly focused while performing
complex tasks
the tool can offer improvements in
visual processing working memory focus
and more
over time with repeated use but what
noah roland and this team have found
is that it could also be used as a tool
for priming cognitive function
in the short term and we started meeting
with customers and prospects
and customers started coming in and
telling us
yeah so this is ball players what's your
feedback well
our hitters love to use neurotrainer
before they go to batting practice
our hitters like to use neurotrainer
before they
they hit the game and that's when we had
resisted priming it was so funny we're
like no we're so focused on the
long-term benefits we can increase your
decision-making speed and this and that
and then i mean there's like this
obvious epiphany that's it's like an
octopus sitting on your face and you're
trying to look around it right
it's athletes and everybody else want to
know
why should i do this today imagine a
future where before flying a passenger
plane
a pilot must first engage in a bit of
brain training to prime themselves for
action
and improve their focus how about a
surgeon
the benefits here are clear by using a
tool like neurotrainer for a brief spell
prior to competition or training an
athlete could theoretically enjoy
greater focus
reactions and performance moreover this
could even result in heightened
plasticity
and thereby greater learning andrew
hubermann discusses a similar topic in
his podcasts
suggesting that hand balancing and
similar activities could increase the
amounts of plasticity promoting agents
in the brain
such as brain-derived neurotrophic
factor the key here is that the activity
be challenging and novel
such that a high error rate encourages
focus and learning and puts the brain in
a state
that's malleable and ready for change so
there's a lot of emerging data around
the importance of errors
90 minutes you know you have a 90 minute
window to go
learn something because the thing isn't
neurotrainer
the thing is yeah that's like a
pre-workout i suppose
right right and and that really i think
um
jamie mentioned um uh andrew huberman's
podcast and he said something very
similar doesn't he about inversions and
handstands
and stuff but obviously not everyone
wants to go doing handstand
so can we get somebody into a
performance state in
six minutes can we do it before because
we can do it i mean as you know you
you're a vr guy
we're hijacking your visual cortex
that's another interesting point to
consider the baseline plasticity of your
brain varies from person to person
which means priming could have a lesser
or greater effect on you
if you're interested in discovering more
about your own personal levels of
plasticity then i highly recommend the
dna analysis tool
self-decode self-decode will analyze
your dna
using a file you may already have from
an ancestry service or similar
or a simple saliva sample this will then
reveal many genetic traits that may
impact on your performance in highly
detailed reports and relevant to this
discussion
was the report regarding my own levels
of bdnf this could reflect
my own levels of plasticity there's a
link in the description down below and
if you follow that i'll get a small
commission
so thanks in advance of course there are
other options if you want to shop around
a bit first
before parting ways i should mention
that priming can happen implicitly
you are constantly being primed by your
environment and your actions and this is
what so often leads to the disconnect
between the way you want to perform
and the reality think carefully about
your environment then
pay just as much attention to what you
put into your brain as you would your
stomach
and especially when it comes to the
moments leading up to an important event
so if you found this video useful and
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like and share around
that helps me out immensely if you like
this kind of discussion that looks at
the interplay between physical and
mental performance
then you'll definitely enjoy my ebook
and training program super functional
training
that's a unique training program and
discussion in that it focuses not only
on strength and aesthetics but also on
mobility
focus cognitive performance creativity
everything all at once
there's a discount on right now during
the pandemic and there's a link in the
description down below
alternatively i also discussed the brain
and its relation to physical performance
a lot
in my print book functional training and
beyond if you want more like this then
please subscribe
either way thank you so much for
watching this one guys i really
appreciate it
and i'll see you next time bye
for now